du jour c'est l'émission samedi soir
c'était bien sûr l'élection de miss
france sur tf1 6,9 millions de
téléspectateurs alors c'est le plus bas
score de miss france depuis 2010 mais
mine de rien pour ça reste un score très
élevé et l'élection se passe à marseille
du coup j'ai envoyé mon correspondant
préféré à marseille rené maleville il
est temps pour nous de préparer le prime
dans le sud de la france
direction marseille
contre des marseillais de leur second
coup je me chie dessus
l'intérim est là et ça va pas layrac
fonctions car jai bats les couilles au
début de la cérémonie on a donc fait la
présentation de tout le monde y compris
du jury ce que tu as déjà fait jury de
miss france samedi n'ont jamais alors on
se souvient d'alain delon de line renaud
cette annonce et on s'attendait voilà
ici cc c'est nicole garcia qui était
président du jury il mansac triste et
regardez là on sent que tf1 aussi dans
le jury ils ont fait ça dans l'urgence
c'était qu'ils apprennent en france mais
on sent qu'ils ont fait le jury dans
l'urgence on sent que frère ils ont
appelé les gars trois jours avant ça
c'est sûr et certain
ça c'est vraiment hésité dans la merde
ils ont pris tous les gars qui habitait
les environs de marseille est sondhi
frérot est ce que tu peux pas vraiment
pas venir même une heure tu regardes
2006 thomas frérot chacun amandine
amandine henry venez venez venez notre
président que la capitaine de l'équipe
de france de football
c'est bien jean-pierre merci beaucoup
vous avez gagné cet après midi oui on a
gagné 2 0 quand tout va bien voilà il y
avait quand même donc vitesse il manie
se lâchent plus relais de son actif aux
îles ce qui alors l'animateur s'est bien
sûr notre jean pierre foucault on adore
jean pire on a remarqué quelque chose
pendant le show je crois qu'il a le même
ophtalmo regardez regardez c'était de
regarder aller là bas mais regardez la
puce de notre j p voilà et j'ai donc en
exclusivité les fiches de jp pour son
début d'émission regarder bonjour tous
[Rires]
mais je connais bien jean pierre et
c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois il voit très
bien jean pierre mais il va chaque fois
des fiches et au parce que ça le rassure
il veut il veut pouvoir vite voir vite
les trucs voilà si si oui mais où normal
parce qu'avec toutes les lumières qu'il
ya c'est très complet savoir lire et
jean pierre qui était formidable
d'ailleurs ça nous prouve
il nous manque aujourd'hui on a envie de
le voir plus dans l'année alors jean
pierre foucault il s'est lâché un petit
peu avec sylvie tellier
regardez l avais rien demandé à personne
qu'il vit est l'agent pierre comme je
connais jamais eu le même dit hacker
regarder la carte ou serré ça fait
bizarre
elles doivent ressentir de même chose
tout comme vous avez ressenti de l'inde
aux médias quelques courtes années
quelques cours des années
alors un des grands moments de stress
pour les miss c'est qu'on va annoncer
les quinze qualifiés et vous allez voir
il y en a une qui ne s'attendait pas du
tout à être qualifié à nous a sorti une
tête et nous accueillons maintenant une
autre qualifiée miss centre val de loire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jeu d'équipé alors ya eu plein de tweets
dessus miss en val de loire quand on a
annoncé qu'elle était sélectionnée
regardez la photo est là c'est évident
mcdo voilà voilà
[ __ ] merde à la base c'était une
blague ça part en couille là on dirait
que tu as une interro surprise prof
sortait une feuille et un stylo contrôle
de connaissances et il ya le grand
moment aussi des discours je voulais
vous montrer mes deux préférés parce que
haussier elles sont élues grâce au
discours est d'abord c'était miss ile de
france
on sait pas pourquoi elle est venue leur
miss france et sa grande passion en fait
elle c'est le bâtiment je suis très
contente d'avoir été appelé parmi les 15
finalistes parce que je m'y attendais
pas du tout et donc je suis en double
dit j'ai vu un double dip l'inde dans le
domaine du bâtiment et des travaux
publics
donc c'est un peu pompeux joue la corde
et vous vous demandez sûrement mais
qu'est ce qu'elle fait là celle-là mais
[Applaudissements]
les gaulois et il y en a une autre aussi
voilà qui a été beaucoup charrier c'est
miss provence
regardez lors de son discours regarde
préférées je n'ai que quelques secondes
pour me présenter à vous alors je n'ai
pas envie de vous raconter des mensonges
je n'ai pas l'habitude des podiums ni
des grandes et belles robes et belle
robe comme celle que je porte ce soir
moi mon quotidien c'est plutôt jean
baskets
les sorties en famille j'aime rire
j'aime manger
j'aime les choses simples de la vie
c'était sympathique on va car le débit
est naturel oui je sais et bien sûr on
va voir le grand vraiment que tout le
monde attendait on n'était que son
stress même moi je n'étais pas bien avec
le suspense la finale c'est vrai
regardez bien miss provence elle était
persuadée le gagner j'étais une des
potes je vais dire regarde c'est normal
elle est sûre de gagner et un moment
vous allez voir jusqu'au dernier au mois
se dit non il ya une vanne six mois
regardez la tête et regarder
[Musique]
miss france 2020 est et restera miss
wattrelos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et là je viens c'est toi qui embrassera
totale parce que toi quand tu es
première dauphine faire et on va ce que
tout le monde et toi tu es tout seul
c'est comme ça tu dois garder et est
dégoûté tu flippes non mais pourquoi
elle
j'étais dans les deux nouveaux frères
pourquoi je me suis fait chier ce qu'on
va pas habiter sur les plateaux la
première dauphine
voilà tu peux inviter une pomme dauphine
mais pas la commère devine tout le monde
va vouloir avoir miss guadeloupe